اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رفح اهلا بكم
الجزيره تحصل على صور لعمليات انتشال
جثامين شهداء متحلله مكبله الايدي ومعصوب
الاعين في مدرسه شماليه قطاع غزه ونادي
الاسير الفلسطيني يصف الامر بانه دليل
واضح على جريمه اعدام صهيونيه بحقهم ووسط
قصف اسرائيلي متواصل استهدف مناطق عده في
قطاع غزه ارتفاع عدد شهداء الح الى نحو 27
ال الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل ضابط
وجنديين في معارك قطاع غزه وسحب اللواء
الخامس في اطار تقليص عدد القوات وجلن
يقول ان من يتحدث عن السيطره عسكريا على
غزه لا يعرف عمق المشكله في حين قالت
كتائب القسام انها استهدفت ثلاث دبابات
اسرائيليه في القطاع واعلنت سرايا القدس
استهداف جنود تحصنوا داخل مبنى بالمنطقه
الوسطى البيت الابيض يؤكد احراز تقدم في
المحادثات للافراج عن الاسرى والتوصل الى
هدنه طويله الامل وهنيه يؤكد ان حماس تدرس
المقترح وفقا لاولو وقف العدوان وانسحاب
الاحتلال من غزه من جانبه قال نتنياهو ان
الجيش لن يغادر القطاع ولن يفرج عن الاف
ممن وصفهم بالارهابيين في حين شددت الكويت
والسعوديه على ضروره وقف العمليات
العسكريه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وحمايه
المدنيين
انصار الله الحوثيون يؤكدون اطلاق صواريخ
على مدمره امريكيه في البحر الاحمر
ويقولون انهم سيستهدف السفن الحربيه
الامريكيه والبريطانيه في بحري العرب
والاحمر دفاعا عن النفس ومفوض السياسات
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي يؤكد ان
القوه الاوروبيه لحفظ الامن في البحر
الاحمر ستبدا عملها بعد نحو اسبوعين الى
اللقاء
ه